ryan gosling is opening up about
parenting his daughters with long-time
partner ava mendes
you don't want to talk or anything
yeah i'll leave town tomorrow after we
pack up i'm not gonna be around for
another year
another year
hey you wanna
get a beer or something
i got someone
so
no
in a new interview with gq uk the la la
land actor reveals how his girls
five-year-old amada and seven-year-old
esmeralda showed him just how fast time
flies by
it's a very surreal experience the 41
year old tells the man quote time in
general is something i think about a lot
now my kids are growing up so fast i
need to keep an eye on the clock in a
way i never used to ryan also admits to
keeping his little ones entertained
during the covet 19 pandemic by doing
what he and eva do best acting in fact
he says they did more acting in
quarantine than in our films
so how did esmeralda and ahmada react to
mom and dad's theatrics well ryan calls
his daughters a tougher crowd but says
he and david did their best
this is not the face of a romantic lead
so this begs the question have the
seven-year-old and five-year-old gotten
a chance to watch dad's work yet
[Music]
so do you prefer to do it here in the
bedroom the bedroom isn't preferred
ryan says the girls haven't seen any of
his films but they have seen one of
ava's her 1999 comedy my brother the pig
was a big hit
then some ancient magic
proved she was right
i'm telling you i'm dead serious the pig
is george
george is the pig
ryan's rare interview about the family
echoes a message ava shared on instagram
back in april 2020 when she responded to
a fan about keeping her personal life
exactly that personal quote i've always
had a clear boundary when it comes to my
man and my kids i'll talk about them of
course with limits but i won't post
pictures of our daily life and since my
children are still so little and don't
understand what posting their image
really means i don't have their consent
and i won't post their image until
they're old enough to give me consent as
far as ryan and i it just works for us
this way to stay private and in february
2020 e.t chatted with ava about raising
her daughters and how parenthood has
affected her career choices acting is
something that you know i will always
love it's just like now that i have
children
i'm kind of extreme there's just so many
things i won't do
like i won't do most of the movies i've
done in the past yes you take them into
consideration of course so a lot of
things are off that list and i don't
want to do anything too violent of
course i don't want to do anything
too sexual or sexual at all or anything
that's you know that may be
you know
too uh
no of course exactly so i'm basically
like disney
i'm all yours you see
that's all that's left
[Music]